[Music]
hello everyone this is strategy session
and today I'm going to talk about the
deferred steinitz
and the strategic ideas that we can find
there to understand this system I chose
four world champions and the fifth one
will be the system that we're talking
about in fact it's going to be very
interesting because these were champions
have similar ideas of handling this
system but it's different they tweaked
it a little bit so the first one I want
to show is between Ella kind against
John er well john ER is not well known
and i don't know him but the way alle
kind handles this position is very
important to note so e4 e5 Knight c6
Bishop b5 a6 Bishop a4 d6 this is the
deferred sign it's it's not as popular
as it was in the 80s and 90s in the past
many people castled actually it there's
castling here instead of Knight f6
Bishop g4 was very popular with the idea
of h3 h5 kind of stopping or deterring
white from taking on g4 but the
classical steinitz is to eventually put
the bishop on d7 and just keep
developing with the black so d4 Bishop
e7 now obviously the first question is
if we can win upon we can't win a pawn
right now because if we take take D
takes e5 black just takes a pawn back
for it and I takes e4 and this is just
very comfortable for black as all these
bishops are
just putting enormous pressure on
Alekhine's position so Ella kind
decides to play d5 98 and Bishop c2 now
this is my first question to the class
what does this position remind you of
what is this similar to can you raise
yeah yeah yeah definitely it looks much
like the King's Indian one of the big
difference being that this Bishop on e7
is awful it doesn't really do anything
there and it should be on g7 instead so
Ella kind has a choice here either to
take on the 7 or play Bishop c2 and when
we trying to think strategically we have
to take a look which one is better we
have to look at the pros and cons can
anybody tell me what's the pros of
keeping the bishop and moving it to see
- yeah well it is wasting a move but it
would still get rid of that y squared
Bishop but yet a good point saying with
Bishop c2 in the long run white might
have ideas attacking well maybe not even
on h7 but at least taking away and
putting pressure on this important
square on f5 but Bishop takes d7 also
has some strategic ideas behind it can
anybody tell me what could be the
potential pros of Bishop takes d7 yeah
yes yes so the bishop on d7 is pretty
good for black so black would like to
keep it if possible on the other hand we
are exchanging of one of our assets the
a4 bishop so it's around 5050 whichever
you feel like both is reasonable but
it's not quite easy to decide which one
is bad
elack I chose Bishop c2 that's one thing
it plans some attacks in the near future
I mean in the upcoming future while also
defending the e4 pawn Bishop g4 I'm not
a big fan of Bishop g4 the reason is I
don't like this move is black commits
this bishop way too early
if black book castle not King f8 Castle
black will have a choice then if white
would say play h3 already white ways to
the tempo so we don't have to go Bishop
g4 which would be a bad idea right now
because they'll just take us but Bishop
g4 is not too good because alekan
already knows what black is planning c4
gaining some space and also planning
Knight c3 97 h3 and this is the main
problem Ella kine is asking a question
way earlier than black could decide if
it's good to take or not good enough to
take was in this position black would
like to have a bishop on c8 and decide
later on if he is going to bring the
bishop on the Kings side or keep it on
c8 for an attacking possibility he
played Bishop g4 way too early and after
97 h3 he has to make an uncomfortable
choice so he decides to keep the bishop
well if he takes on f3 the problem is
that white gets the bishop therefore not
much these bishops will be extremely
powerful and also white loses one of its
best pieces Bishop h5 Knight c3 Castle
g4 Bishop g6 alright because we're
talking about strategy let's take stock
who is better and why any ideas
yeah the black is not really developed
and also what about the black pieces
what can we say about them yet black
pieces are kind of passive but we have
to pinpoint which pieces are very bad in
blacks position yes yes
they basically this Bishop on g6 is
terrible
and even though e7 is bad but you can't
do much with it this Bishop on g6 is
hopeless
in general black might go 98 on Bishop
g5 if given the chance and there's a
hope for this Bishop to get better but
this Bishop is stuck on g6 forever
correct
so you could say that Allah kind just
outplayed his opponent already Queen e2
98 johner just follows the plan that I
just mentioned he's trying to get it get
rid of that Bishop on e7 Bishop d2 h6
King g2 now King g2 is this typical
human move that I really like it's this
idea of not showing the two intentions
but still let's think about it what what
is Alec I'm preparing with King G - yes
yeah
yeah so yes so king g2 is a great move
because it's ambiguous it doesn't show
any true intentions but I might still go
on and play on the Queen side but it
also hints at ideas at rook H one H four
g5 and if my manages to crash through on
the king's that it would be over it'll
be checkmate
Bishop eight seven Rock h1 g5 so black
chooses a plan that usually is not good
because he closes off the position and
hopes that he won't get checkmated but
that usually doesn't work you have to
stay passive and defend a closed
position you can't totally close it off
because you will have no counter play at
all
so Allah kind played h4 yep 691 where is
that night headed yep
yeah five of course mine is going to f5
93 9f5
but as we will see Alec kind is not in a
big rush
he knows that sooner or later he's going
to crash through so he's very patient
who kept 793 not a faith Knight f5
why was Knight f5 very important in this
moment actually a very crucial moment
yes yes yes so Knight g6 is a threat for
black and if he manages to get there it
will jump to f4 and oh nope
so 9 f8 and the plan will be to go to f4
and not f4 and occupying this important
square on that 4 and if black manages to
do that it's getting unclear
so therefore Allah kind plays Knight f5
takes takes and now this all-important
g6 square is protected so the first
thing first Ella kind pushed his
opponent off the board and then stopped
him from
having any concert play at all so G
takes f five located seven Mooji 197
King F one can we pinpoint what alekan
is playing for at the moment obviously
he wants to crash through but Ella kind
just brings his pieces as we see that
but he doesn't show his true intentions
black is still guessing what might wants
to do we don't know what might wants it
could be about anything
there's the only thing we know at the
moment that the rooks are on these two
half open files they have very nice
pressure on those pawns but we don't
know what Alec is real plan is and
that's a good thing they're more
ambiguously play in these strategic
positions the hardest for your opponent
to decide how to defend so Queen e8
night eh - now Ella kind is revealing
something he's kind of planning of
jumping to g4 and hitting these vital
spots on h6 and f6 Knight h5 hoping to
go to f4 but it's not as good as it was
before
not g4 9 f4 Queen f3
now how many good pieces does black have
one and that's not enough so therefore
it's clear that white is much much
better if not near winning king g7 each
takes g5 takes rook takes rook h1 now if
you notice it Ella kind exchanges of the
only potentially active piece and that
was the rook on h7 and now after he got
rid of that good piece he attacks this
terrible piece on h7 King h8 he plays
King h8 because white is threatening
ideas of Bishop f4 and Queen age
three and then invading talking h8r okay
six now notice that Ella kind doesn't
want to force action
he wants his opponent to keep guessing
what he's up to he doesn't take on f4
immediately he'll choose they're just
the right moment went to take Queen f7
Bishop d1 what's the idea of dish of d1
I know it's a mysterious move but what
could it be
yeah yes yes so basically the idea as
you correctly pointed out is to take on
f4 at some opportune moment and in fact
transfer this bishop after a long long
maneuvering to h5 and g6 and then it's
going to be made correct yes so Bishop
d1 that's the main idea of this move
rook g8 Queen b3 now Queen b3 is a
typical Ella kind move he dominated the
Kings side so he turns his attention to
the Queen side which is very typical of
him and one of his biggest assets in his
chest
b6 now he took no he didn't Bishop f8 he
took on a6 there's no taking because
Knight takes h6 and that's what happened
queen c8 and coming back just for a
second in this position already black is
in big trouble because if he plays a5 I
attack you from the sides and I will
have double threats winning the c7 pawn
while you're still kind of stuck
defending on the Kings side
so therefore G owner decides to find
some other way of finding a counter play
but he still fails not a fate Bishop
takes a four he takes F for now I really
like this move by a lock on Bishop takes
f4
because he's exchanging as much as he
can when he's upon up and it's very
important to note and you have a winning
position exchanges are good for you
obviously don't exchange the whole board
off but if you keep enough material on
the board the exchanges should favor you
Feeny 8 another very nice move just
taken away all the squares from the
black Queen so it's kind of stuck there
g4 bh5 just attacking these weak pawns
f3 Bishop a4 9 8 7 bishop see - well
Ella Khan is not doing much now he's
just waiting 9 f8 and he plays d5 d6 e5
and here Ella kind finds a very very
classy way of winning the position d6
the same ideas you had sir the bishop
wants to enter through d5 now he Joan
are played c5 and after Bishop b4 he
resigned as either the D pawn promotes
or the bishop just checkmates on d5 it
was very important though to play d6
first because this is the most forcing
way to win if C takes D six Mike can
even play this move up c5 because nobody
can take the pawn because I just check
you and I went because this thread is
just way too strong otherwise I can just
take the pawn and just be winning or
even Bishop b3 is a win so that was one
way of handling this Stein is deferred
of not taking on d7 so that was our
first vote champion who played against
this system in this lecture let's see Oh
car puffs way of handling this so it's a
45 93 96 but should be 5 g6 now this is
a different move order but it will
transpose to these typical Steinitz
positions c3 a6 Bishop a4 d6 and here we
are in Steinitz
territory d4 Bishop d7 Castle Bishop g7
now the best way to learn strategies is
to think think about the position and
come up with original ideas so we
already have one plan what was the plan
that we first learned yeah play d5 of
course but let's look at this position
and let's come up with some other plans
because that's not the only plan you can
play in this type of positions maybe you
can find car pop splat mm-hmm yeah
Bishop g5 is a very good idea yes so you
were suggesting the move h3 and with the
plans of g4 h3 is a good move usually
because you will take away this g4
square from the bishop so that's great
but always be very with the g4 ideas
does g4 ideas as we saw from the
previous game in the Alekhine game was
good because the bishop was already on
h5 if the bishop doesn't move to h5 g4
is not such a good idea
okay so Bishop g5 is a very very good
idea
it's not what Karpov played but it's a
good way kind of you anticipated what
black is going to do and if the knight
moves we have six it runs into a pin and
we're just happy about that or or 97 so
Bishop g5 is actually one of the
favorites of Viswanathan Anand the world
champion who just recently won the rapid
world championship
he also likes this move of bothering the
black queen but actually black has a
funny move here that been fine goes wilt
hate to see and that's f6 now the reason
f6 could work in this position is that
the night on g8 is not developed yet and
strangely enough in closed position
being undeveloped can has its perks
for example bishop eats me now black has
this crazy little move called knight h6
and if the bishop moves to b3 black will
go queenie 792 and knight f7 basically
building a shelter so he can Castle
kingside
the very interesting play I'm not saying
black is equalizing but it it's actually
very interesting Nigel short still plays
this line with black so it shouldn't be
too bad but your strategic idea of
Bishop g5 and then developing your
pieces that's a very good idea
Karpov as he's more of a classicist
likes to develop all his pieces
classically played rookie 197 and put
his Bishop to e3 now we're going to see
a different method of playing against
this D 6 e 5 structure core Pope says I
have the bigger center therefore I
should be better here and that is why he
decides not to close the center and just
play for the space advantage 92 Queen e8
actually the screen eight is quite a
nasty move what does Spassky have in
mind what is he planning to do next
yeah and I takes d4 so if I'm
unsuspecting play h3 then boom die d4
and Bishop d7 usually would win but the
problem is Knight takes f3 is checked
and we would be a pawn down and that
won't be a fun game afterwards so Karpov
doesn't fall for cheap tricks
he plays Bishop b3 just as I mentioned
before this Bishop is very powerful on
this diagonal and is most of the times
very happily plays there now Karpov has
another threat that's pasti will deal
with in the upcoming move Karpov wants
to take and if takes then Bishop c5
putting pressure on the e7 square let me
show you how so Bishop b3 if King h8 d
takes e5 D takes and Bishop c5 and b6 is
not enough because I'm obviously not
going to take on the e7 when I play
Bishop a3 and then I have nasty-nasty
threats along these two diagonals also I
have a little bit more space because
this Bishop on d7 is kind of cramped
this DS and d7 and the knight on e7 is a
bit cramped
so Spassky comes up with a good
defensive move namely b6 stopping that
idea for good he takes e5 he takes e5
and there's one big difference when we
play this classical way compared to the
d5 way of playing which looks more like
a King's Indian that in this case black
will be risking something if he plans to
play f5 obviously it's not legal now but
later on we'll see how risky it is to
play for that night c4 hitting the 5
pawn immediately
which is defended at the moment but that
only means that the knight on c6 can't
move at all King h8 Queen c1 alright so
what's our first impression of this
position yeah so yeah it is close to
equal but white has some little bit of a
pool any other ideas about the position
yeah
Bishop h6 is a very big threat than
actually Karpov is playing for that
trying to undermine this e5 pawn so
spassky's seeing that could come up with
two options one of the options that he
has is not been fine Gold's favorite
what move is that yes
f6 now Spassky didn't know that Ben
hates that move so maybe that's why he
didn't play it oh yeah if he would have
known that maybe he would have played it
but f6 paradoxically would have been a
pretty good move because for one it
defends the e5 pawn to black can't hope
for a Kings Indian kind of play can
anybody guess what plan
Spassky can build in this position it
kind of looks weird for the untrained
eye but it would be pretty strong here
what planet could black have in this
position
yes g5 I'm not sure about Queen h5 the
g5 move is pretty good so let's say h3
let's make some moves g5 and what plan
could black have in mind in this
position yes Nigeria at 4 and actually
this is a very very strong plan just
molding and just finding that outpost
for the night and that would be amazing
for black because this e 7 night is not
too happy on e7 and would just have a
ball if it reaches f4 so f6 would have
been the best move here even though it's
a tough move to make because that will
close this Bishop on g7 forever so he
played Bishop g4 in now Karpov played a
very interesting idea Knight g5
seemingly a weird move and I guess
Spassky was asking that question what
are you going to do with that after h6
but Karpov had an idea in mind so it's
white to move and solve and of the issue
of the night it's more of a strategic
idea it's not to tactical obviously y
doesn't want to bring the knight back
because then we'll have very bad pawn
structure yes
yes h3 well every it's not good because
he just moved the bishop and then you'll
have to move the knight I'll take you
and then you'll have this very very sad
structure that you don't like
also this f3 pawn will be very weak so
h3 that's the correct move as you
suggested and I think this surprised
Spassky because the knight will have a
very nice place on f3 and black is just
losing tempi everywhere Bishop d7
933 engage seven in that this is still
the slow maneuvering game I still feel
like this slightly better and black is
kind of suffocated because of all these
passive pieces on the Queen side namely
c6 D seven and seven pieces a for now 84
is kind of gaining a little bit of space
while also taking away this idea of b5
so he plays at five and this is the
thing I was talking about f5 in these
half open positions are not such a great
idea
because I take of course because I want
to open up the position if black would
manage to play f4 he'd have an amazing
attack the g5 h5 and all those kings in
the near Kings Indian shining against so
it takes f5 G takes f 5 and here Karpov
played a very very nice tactical idea
yes
yes now I take c5 I take c5 takes takes
Bishop h6 and this is actually very
typical sometimes and even in the
classical Kings Indian you get these
half-open structures and typically there
are these kind of sacrifices with 95 the
problem here for black is that there's
no Bishop g7 is that because Queen g5
but I can just take immediately and
Queen g5 that's maybe even easier and
now the rook will just take on e7 and
I'm just winning now the biggest problem
for black is that even though he'll be
some material up all his pieces are so
dis coordinated that he's just
inadvertently going to be worse so you
played Bishop d6 Queen g5 just putting a
lot of threat and just threatening Queen
g7 here Queen g6 low key 7 takes takes
King takes h6 it takes d7 and now let's
take stock how do we stand materialize
in this position with white
yeah well I wouldn't say equal i mean
equal materialized that's true but
what's better for white yeah the blacks
position it's very very important
this King on h6 is without shelter
meanwhile karpova's King is very safe on
g1 but all these healthy pawns defending
it
f4 well Spassky is trying to find some
counter chances but Karpov is not scared
of anything
and f3 wouldn't scare him because he'd
either played g4 and the king will come
up with king h2 and queen g3 and now
it's already three pawns so that's more
than enough
in general I'd say that white is better
because of the King safety and also if
usually if you have two pawns and a
piece that should be more than enough to
compensate the material deficit okay it
rook to e1 once the planner for Dean 1
yes
yeah real d7 or room d6 but a good thing
here too that we just activated all of
our pieces the Queen the bishop the rook
are very active and it's very good
compared to blacks position where the
most active pieces this Queen on g6 so
we can safely say that white is much
much better
rook f6 engage to just getting out of
these tricks of f3 so King H 2 a 5
rook d4 just trying to gobble a little
bit more pawns with the idea for cat for
Brooke a faith rook d7 rook c6 Queen e5
be enough 6 Queen d5 oak c5 Queenie for
and Spassky had enough because of Queen
G's if Queen g6 is played we would have
a very very nice move here but white
which is kind of easy but still need to
find it why to move and gain a decisive
attack
yeah yeah Queeny seven and now the
problem is one for one I'm hitting on
your rook the other one the other
problem is if let's say rook f6 you have
a very nice little Intermezzo in this
position yeah Bishop to c2 and you can't
defend both the eight seven square and
the rook so you're basically lost so if
you take I mean takes f6 and I'm winning
so carpals way of playing was much
different to Alekhine's he was more
focusing on keeping his strategic
advantage of Center and just slowly
grinded away Ella kind was more of
combining positional play with an
aggressive attack so we saw two games
from these were champions let's see how
computers handle this position in fact
one of them is a real champion yes so
this game is played between Houdini
Komodo and Houdini and they're playing
this position and this is kind of very
similar to the positions we saw g6
Bishop e3 very close to the way that
Karpov played Bishop g7 d5 but this is
kind of a bit strange or for a human not
too logical because as we saw when Alec
I'm play d5 he didn't play Bishop e3
necessarily if white played Bishop e3
usually he continued that 92 and rookie
one it doesn't mean that White's plan is
bad it's just unusual for the human eye
the 598 c4 so why does what is white
going for here what's our first guess
yeah pushing getting that advantage and
the board yeah - yes yeah
so white is going for the space
advantage and for some type of king's
indian positions where this bishop is a
little bit misplaced on these seven
castles takes knight c3 okay so this is
very reasonable white has this extra
space extra space with these c-44 pawn
structure but black still has feinting
chances because black is already
developed and everything is ready for an
attack especially the idea of playing f5
is just on the table so h6
before f5 he must play h6 because if he
plays f5 right now I have a very typical
idea and that is 9 g5 and the knight
would hop in to e6 e 6 and that would be
terrible
so he plays h6 92 at 5 f3 now compared
to King's Indian what can we say about
this position what's the difference here
yeah the bishops are missing is that
good for black yeah it's bad for black
so usually this should favor white and
as we will see it does on the other hand
black is very well developed the piece
is the night on d7 and e7 is very well
placed at the moment because they're
ready to support any kind of King side
or Queen side action that could happen
so black has some chances here King h7
Queen b3 now Queen b3 I'm not fond of
this is the typical computer move which
looks nice at first sight and might even
be the strongest move
but if we look forward in time we might
realize that we would rather have this
Queen on c2 rather than on b3 or even on
e - now I'm not saying that Queen b3 is
bad it's just not part of a larger plan
that usually humans aim for so Queen B 8
which is also a little bit weird
I prefer B 6 because black could keep
this structure this is very King's India
like so what Queen b8 is fine - bishop
f2 h h5 rogue d1 why did white play rook
F do you want it's a pretty good move
yes
yeah it's preparing night maneuvers with
Knight f1 but it also prepares the
defense of the d2 night so that's
important Bishop h6 so actually Komodo
thought correctly that Bishop h6 is
coming a 4 C 5
a 5 I like this plan this a 4 a 5 plan
is very good what could be the long-term
benefit of having this a 485 idea in
this structure yes
so why will eventually play ideas like
before
that's it Queen c2 Queen Queen c7 Queen
c2 and now we understand why we wanted
the Queen on c2 originally because I was
forced to make the move Queen c2 anyways
and again this is kind of preparing the
idea of b4 mostly after this preparatory
move of rook do you want Rudy B 1 and B
4 so route b8 King H 1 B 6 a takes rook
takes B six will be one out of six
Bishop e1 now would it favor black to
take on e4 or not that's my question
from a strategical point of view would
that be a great idea to take on e4
yes why not as we're saying that if we
keep the pond we have g5g for ideas yeah
but what's wrong with the idea of taking
on e4 what does that allow for white
yeah we get an outpost yeah yeah see
takes three four takes takes and now
white would have a brilliant strategic
position as this Knight is powerful here
and we're also kind of getting very
close to break with b4 so this is
basically strategically winning yes what
yeah but it's black to move
yeah Knight f5 94 would be an idea for
black but then Bishop a5 would come so
that's kind of the tactical problem with
blacks position therefore houdini
doesn't take on e4 which is a good
strategic decision in place King g7r
okay three Queen c8 rook a1 white is
preparing to assault that a6 pawn rook
f7 bishop f2 Queen B eight well it seems
that black is kind of waiting not doing
too much although I don't know what
Bishop f2 once exactly but it's never
too bad to put up this battery and that
might be useful later on Queen b8 the
computer will not blunder the b2 pawn
king gate 7 bishop e1 King g7 h3 so
they've been waiting around for a while
now
Queen c8
in d3 mind you why wouldn't take on a 6
because the b2 upon would be hanging and
that would have been a bad trade for
white so he never takes on a 6
laughter h3 Houdini decides to defend
the a6 pawn anyways green d3 King gauge
7 King g1 and to be honest I don't see
concrete plans for either side much or
they're not showing any signs of plans
at the moment 97 now 97 is a committal
decision by black coz 97 comes then
black loses the grip on the e4 pawn and
even though black never takes on e4 it's
one of those important squares in these
type of positions because if white
doesn't have enough defenses on e4 it's
most probably going to be a good
position for black but white also needs
to defend that pawn and I guess that's
the reason why there was this shadow
fighting between the two computers
neither of them wanted to release the
tension okay but now Houdini gave in and
played 97 planning to regroup or do
something
Queeny to an IG 8 and here comes the
regrouping he thinks or plans that Hugo
na GA and Knight f6 thinking that the
knight will stand much better on f6 than
on e7 which will turn out to be false 91
a very nice plan Knight f6 Knight f2 so
white takes the time to maneuver himself
or itself and plays 93 and this maneuver
is very typical of the Kings Indian then
that is very well placed on d3
because this prepares any ideas of
sacrificing or just coming up with plans
of B 4 and C 5 so this was a very
beneficial maneuver for komodo and this
was a strong one as well
97 and now Houdini realized that he
can't do anything anyways and he's just
waiting now King age one now this King
gauge one move is useful
why is King age one so useful in this
position yeah yeah just getting out of
checks that's all so anytime if he will
start doing some maneuvers with b4 or
anything else he won't be in Queen C 5
checks which don't make sense at the
moment but can happen any time also
Black has plans of Bishop e3 Bishop d4
sometimes so if your king is on h1
that's at least not a check so King g8
is played row k3 King gauge - he takes
f5g takes a five-mile f1 and this is a
typical way of just destroying a Kings
Indian structure white gives up the
centre plays Knight f1 but for given
away the center black got weaknesses
there are those weaknesses that yes
not really the e-cigs because it's well
protected it's mostly the f5 pond that
it's weak and the h5 bomb and the
problem for black is that he either
going to checkmate or lose now it's
going to be the other case black is
going to lose Queen g8 and that drops
the palm now and we'll stop there
because the computer will just finish
off afterwards just keep the pond and
when the problem was here that white has
this very brutal threat of Nigeria
double attacking both the f5 and h5
ponds and there's not much black can do
about it because if he moves his night
away
I might have B for ideas and sooner or
later your position crumbles so after
Queen g8 Luke takes a6 later on Komodo
one that good technique but comes game
to where the sides switch and Houdini
plays the white colored so he's so
Houdini is white in this game
d6 c3 d4 97 d5 Knight b8 Houdini plays
with Bishop c2 which is normal we saw
this before right yeah this is the other
kind way of handling nygean here
Houdini comes up with a novel and very
interesting idea and actually I think we
can find it if you can pinpoint various
blacks
biggest weakness in this position which
square is relatively weak in this
position this Bishop on c2 is very
useful right now because it supports
this pawn the pawn that has a firm grip
on this
we're we're really hoping to use yes the
f5 square so the D me comes up with this
very very interesting idea of night a3
which is by no means very human Houdini
yeah he is planning to move around and
go through our five so this is a very
very concrete way of attacking this
position saying that oh I'm going to go
through this route and this will be
amazing and what's fascinating about
this that black can't really do much
about it because if he plays b5 which
would be the first human reaction
stopping white from going there then
white would just look jump back and the
idea would be to play a4 and compared to
these Kings Indian positions white has
already made attack on the Queen side so
it's quite possible that Houdini just
found the best move in this position
Bishop e7 Knight see for a five I'm not
sure about a five because what is not
really planning to go Knight a5 it's not
a real threat
a5 but okay if five is a normal move g3
now can anybody tell me what's the idea
of GZ yeah it's one of the reasons is to
just smother this not on g6 also using
this idea of h4 h5 but mostly taking it
away this f4 square because it's pivotal
age 693 Houdini is going for his plan
not f8 9 f8 I don't like because it's a
plan that will not do much I think black
should castle and hope for the best but
I think white is already much much
better not f8 a for just stopping any
idea
of advancing the pond a 4 9 8 7 B 3 just
defending Knight f6 and now the reason I
don't like this maneuver that black
managed to bring the Knights we have six
that you could do in one move now he
wasted like three moves on it so it
could have been the best move in the
position but it still feels bit off 92
very good plan
Bishop h3 because why it is planning to
play Ella kind like and go crazy on the
kingside Bishop Age 3
Queenie to h5 Bishop e3 just getting
ready to castle and develop 97 f3 now
the idea is to take away this g4 Square
g6 in here Houdini comes up with another
very nice maneuver and she gets rid of
the only active piece that black has
if we go g4 he'll take it we do love the
bishop but we give some space for our
opponent we don't want to do that yeah
yes an ID one in 9f2
so Houdini is sharing very nice
maneuvers in this position I'd be six
Knight f2 Bishop c8 castles and we can
see just by looking at this position
that this is amazing for white he has
the center he has everything ready for a
King side attack me and my black is
struggling in developing pieces 97
another sad move that we don't really
want to make f4 and after b6 Knight f3
just bringing more pieces into the game
castle f5 and f5 is a very good move
it's kind of signaling that okay we're
going to play for two results now either
I'm going to win are we going to draw if
you fight really well maybe you draw but
these are computers so it's not likely
to happen
King g7 King b1 okay Jade h3 and the
reason why I'm saying that that white
has so much initiative going on and so
many good pieces attacking that's
unlikely it'll end in a draw at age 7
how can we bring in some more pieces to
attack
yeah yeah bishop c1 just putting some
pressure on g5 which is an important
square if black could manage to set foot
there he could hope maybe to draw
somehow Bishop c1 bishop a 6c for black
tries to do something on the Queen side
but after c4 it's all closed down
there's nothing going to happen there g5
rook f1 not h f8 h h9 h 2o k 7h for g4
and Houdini comes up with the most
powerful plant possible here yes yes
now g4 it's time to sacrifice for the
initiative and this kind of reminds me
of the game played between Wesley so and
calm ski where you have these positional
peace sacrifices you have just so many
pieces attacking your opponent's king
there's no way your opponent can survive
and Komodo will not survive 9 things g4
especially as these pawns will start
marching and there's no stopping them
King h8 Rho G 1 rook c8 9 8 6 g4 g5 and
even if Komodo would give back some
material that won't be enough because my
rooks will just double on the G line and
I'm just gonna crash through okay
Queen f8 takes Knight g4 exchanging off
that healthy defender now g8 of 6 of the
8 h5 stingy not giving that on away
Ruby 8 rook g3 and then Komodo decided
to resign a very well-played game by
Houdini and actually that 93 plan was
very exciting
and novel compared to the other games so
last but not least I want to show the
fourth world champion and that is Anand
against Milan uke Anand who's still in
his prime were getting back there as he
just won the rapid world championship
was a very good player in the 90s
already and this is one of his very good
games that he played at that time same
variation the steinitz d4 g6 Bishop III
g7 d5 so he plays the same way as we saw
from the computers and b8 c4 and my mom
seems to like the idea of also having a
center
I'd have six so now this is going to be
different the games we saw was mostly 97
Knight of 6 Knight c3 Castle takes takes
an ID - so this is a slightly worse
version for black as this Knight is not
too well placed here
most likely the knight should be on e7
as shown in the computer game c6 castle
rook c8 Queenie to rook c7 and now Anand
plays a move that we've seen before
that's pretty good
it's very nice conceptual move yes No
see if I would lose a pawn
so he played Luke fd1 just defending
this night on d2 also hinting at ideas
later on if time comes and it's needed C
takes d5 how should we take back yes he
takes d5 because if you take eat eggs d5
this pawn can become a little bit weak
on c4 and black will have a real threat
of marching with f5 f4 and it's very
double-edged so C takes d5 is clearly
the best b5 9 c4 was threatened
so black stops that f3 just bolstering
the center on e4 and the e4 pawn queen
b8 how can we break through on the Queen
side yeah a4 of course just pointing out
that this b5 pawn is very weak with the
a sexpot but black is forced to play d4
Knight a 2 and now black has big
problems as this night is going to jump
to c4 so Molyneux cloaks for some other
counter chances with Knight c5 but here
anon comes up with a very nice practical
decision so why to move and get the
advantage yeah yeah an undecided that
even though the bishop is very powerful
it's worth the pawns
so we'll just get those pawns them look
c59 b3 just feeling that extra Tempe
because the a6 pawn is going to drop
anyways
Queen takes a6 Bishop h6 and now comes
the counter chance and this is the sign
of a grandmaster he takes every chance
he gets to bring in pieces that could
create a counter play Knight a5 but
sadly for him this night was jumped to
c6
and after it arrives they're all
counterplay is gone you have some checks
with this rook but it won't be enough
I mean see seven night before so
technically why this two pawns up but
he's gonna lose the b2 one will be one
exchanging of that pesky work on B to
check engage one takes takes 97 93
King g7 green b7 and now black is
utterly lost because he will have to
exchange the Queen's takes takes a5 and
black for good reason resigns because
there's no real way of stopping the plan
of a6 and Ruby 7 a7 therefore on on 1 so
I don't know if you guessed it but
Houdini was 2000 2017 strongest computer
so it was the strongest computer meaning
he Houdini was the world champion
of 2017 and on this a password champion
and the other two was Karpov and Karpov
and Alec on
[Music]